what's going on guys I'm clearly in a
hotel because I am currently in San
Diego my wife and I went to comic-con
and we're having a lot of fun meeting a
lot of really sweaty people and becoming
sweaty ourselves and we decided to take
a break from all that I wasn't saw
valerian the city of a thousand planets
I apologize for the quality of this
review I obviously was not able to take
my audio equipment or my camera
equipment to San Diego on a plane it's
not happening so I'm going up on my
phone
valerian and the city of a thousand
planets takes place in a very strange
universe that's kind of like a
combination of Star Wars The Matrix and
Avatar and in this film is a race of
people that were wrongfully exterminated
their planet completely gone and they're
fleeing they're extremely low in numbers
and the record of this event has been
erased by some very evil people and Dane
DeHaan as valerian and cara delevingne i
believe is how you say her name is his
partner in crime and they are trying to
solve this case and hopefully rescue
this dwindling civilization from
annihilation then this movie looked
really interesting to me I thought it
looked extremely visually spectacular
from all the trailers that I saw which
is just one because I decided after the
first trailer okay I've seen enough and
Lucas on directed it who made films like
the professional and the Fifth Element
I don't know what to think of this movie
actually I really have no idea the
future of this film because I can tell
that it definitely has an audience I
feel like it's one of those movies that
will develop a very hardcore cult
following and years from now people are
still going to be talking about it and
it'll have really passionate fans who
encourage other people to see it because
it's so weird but it's storytelling I
found very uneven its attempts at humor
I also found very uneven and the
chemistry between the leads I found
pretty much non-existent I like Dane
DeHaan quite a bit I've liked him in
movies like the place beyond the pines
and this year he was very strange and
the equally strange a cure for wellness
and I thought it was really good in that
film but I do not buy him as the
universe's most badass soldier I just
I'm sorry I mean I love the guy as an
actor but I didn't really feel him in
that role and I don't think he really
sold it I would say Cara Delevingne was
better than him probably a little bit
better than Dane DeHaan but at the same
time it kind of felt like both of them
were just looking really good for the
camera and that could have something to
do with the fact that pretty much all of
this movie was shot in front of a green
screen it's tough I know for actors to
continue to stay in character when
they're interacting with nothing and
there is a ton of CG in this movie and
some of it as I said is visually
stunning there's a sequence where
valerian is running through multiple
environments extremely fast he's plowing
through walls in this protective suit
that he has on and the colours that fly
by and the environments we quickly see
it was an amazing sequence some of the
action in this movie is really
breathtaking and I have to say it does
feel very original even though it does
kind of seem like a lot of different
things that we have seen before just
told in a semi unique way
Rihanna shows up and has a very unique
whole dancing scene that was something
to behold that's for sure the film has a
lot of things to like in it it's just
that if you take it at its base level
from a storytelling perspective it
disappointed me it was highly uneven and
it goes through so many different tones
and like I said I'd really did not think
any of the humor worked at all I think
my biggest issue with the humor is that
so much of it depends on the chemistry
between the two leads and since I wasn't
really feeling that spark a lot of
Redeemer diss fizzled and as I said I
didn't really think that Dane DeHaan
sold this role of the biggest badass in
the universe you can do just about
anything physically and it just it
didn't really work for me
fortunately but at its heart the heart
of this movie there's some fun to be had
I think this movie will gain a following
and similar to the Fifth Element which
which took a while to get more popular
but I think the fifth element is a much
better film and certainly the
professional if you've never seen those
films check those out I'm going to give
valerian in the city of a thousand
planets a/c guys thank you very much for
watching I also want to give a big thank
you to two amazing fans that I met at
comic-con who surprised my wife and I
with this gift Joker and Harley Quinn
didn't have to do that that was really
sweet of you guys thank you so much you
guys are the best and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
my nice
[Music]
you